[Music]
my name's Matthew Garrett I work at
Google on various internal security
related things what I'm talking about
today is not any sort of official
position of my employer you may be able
to guess as we go along so for some
background I've been working on firmware
for a while now my first LCA
presentation was on a CPI back in 2006
and things have just been getting worse
from there today rather than talking
about how specific aspects of firmware
are terrible or poorly implemented or
just otherwise bad I'm going to be
focusing very much on the security of
firmware itself when we're talking about
security of systems we often only look
at the layers of the software stack that
are easily visible to us we tend to
ignore a lot of the underlying detail
partly because it's as previously
mentioned scary and bad but also because
it's largely hidden from us by the
kernel and other components so to begin
with we need to define what firmware
really is so computers have one core
competency which is executing code
everything else they're terrible at
running code is basically the only thing
that you can trust a computer to do but
there's some irony in the fact that when
you turn the computer on it's not very
good at running code those of you who
are in Stewart's presentation earlier
will have heard some of the ways in
which you have to really control a
computer into getting to the stage where
it's enthusiastic about running code
which you know there's an understandable
position to hold so firmware is the code
that is responsible for getting your
computer into the state that we would
generally recognize as being a computer
firmware is responsible for stuff like
making RAM work which is a pretty
fundamental part of the entire process
but a computer that is only getting to
the stage of initializing itself to the
state of being able to run code is still
not particularly useful that's basically
equivalent to the commodore 64 you turn
it on and excellence you've got a prompt
and now it's time to write your own boot
loader so firmware these days gives you
the interfaces that allow you to
actually run the codes that's then going
to load the rest of your operating
system firmware also abstracts away
various details of hardware on some
platforms some machines there's no
firmware or there's a very thin layer of
firmware that still exists after a
system bring up on other systems there's
quite a lot of firmware and that
firmware is responsible for hiding the
fact that hardware vendors keep changing
how things work and not telling you and
just fixed up in firmware the correct
interface uses the firmware the firmware
makes it all work and finally one that
people don't often realize
firmware is often considered to be in
some sort of privileged position in
terms of the overall system firmware on
x86 platforms is able to access certain
hardware resources that can't otherwise
be accessed is there to mediate access
to those resources so for instance
system management mode which I'm going
to get on to later is responsible for
permitting you to write to the flash
chip on your board and this prevents the
operating system from just being able to
over at your flash which means this also
prevents malware from being else just
overwrite your flash but there's
something that all of these things have
in common and that is that fundamentally
firmware is code which is good because
otherwise it wouldn't run but the
downside of its being code is that human
beings are not particularly good at
writing code a significant portion of
the time while we're sitting there
writing code we're actually writing bugs
you would not believe how many bugs I
can write in the minute and give me a
few hours yeah we're I'm very good at it
so code contains bugs which means your
firmware being made of code almost
certainly contains bugs and this is
increasingly true as firmware becomes
larger firmware brings new features and
firmware it just does more there's a lot
more code the number of bugs per line of
code remains relatively constant so
adding more codes tends to mean adding
more bugs but why do we care about bugs
in the firmware fundamentally this comes
back to the things the firmware is
responsible for the firmware is there to
make your computer work in the beginning
it's fair to then give you the
interfaces you need to lose an operating
system if your firmware ceases behaving
in a trustworthy manner if your firmware
it starts executing malicious code you
can no longer trust that's any of the
rest of the codes the runs on your
system is itself trustworthy you're now
in a situation where your firmware can
compromise your bootloader your
bootloader can compromise your kernel
your kernel can then inject backdoors
into other bits of code this isn't some
hypothetical we've seen firmware based
root kits that are in the wild that are
used to attack operate mmm sorry used to
attack operating systems such that even
if you do a clean reinstall of the
operating system the system is still
compromised even if you switch out the
hard drive the system is still
compromised so firmware security is a
real concern it's not just some
hypothetical
so you might be thinking well okay
what's the attack surface for firmware
how does an attacker actually take
advantage of any of these bugs in the
way this allows them to do something
malicious and something I haven't really
mentioned here is that well obviously
firmwares you generally contained on a
small chip on the motherboard
someone with physical access to the
system is potentially able to just
directly tamper with the firmware so
physical access is an attack surface
that's something that we can't do a
great deal about by writing more code so
it's largely out of scope here so far
the industry approach to handling the
physical access portion of things is
either don't execute the firmware unless
the firmware has a valid signature which
is what Intel's boots carts technology
does or alternatively have the firmware
be measured into some sort of TPM type
device at boot time so you are you are
potentially still executing malicious
code but you're able to determine after
the fact that the codes was malicious
but otherwise firmware still has to deal
with stuff firmware has to be able to
load your bootloader and that means it
needs to take code and put it somewhere
and potentially pass some of that binary
and then execute it so in the old days
on bios-based systems this wasn't so
much of an issue because the way we
executed the bootloader was that you
just took a disk you read the first 512
bytes off the disk and then you just
jumped into them I'm sorry slack has
suddenly decided to demand attention
this is what I get for a running
proprietary software okay so
in the old days not so much of an issue
binaries were not something that was
passed by the firmware these days your
bootloader is a peak off object it needs
the firmware it needs to take this file
to change the even verify Krita graphic
signature on it relocated and excused it
and that's a lot of stuff to do and
giving something a suitably malformed
binary is potentially a way to get into
a path of code execution you shouldn't
be in and cause bad things to happen
systems that are able to read boot loads
of file systems as opposed to just off
raw disk or flash also have to parse the
file system but also there's frequently
a bunch of runtime interfaces that are
presented to the operating system by the
firmware so the operating system is able
to make use of the firmware to do
various things this isn't some sources
so it's very easy to demonize UEFI
here's you if I does provide an
interesting number of runtime services
that have quite a lot of code behind
them but who here ever programs for dos
wow I'm so sorry that's a loss of you
right so you remember making BIOS
interrupts right so doing things in DOS
meant calling int whatever
that's all run time firmware code now
generally speaking in DOS you didn't
really care whether your firmware was
insecure in terms of if you called a
certain interrupt with sufficiently
invalid arguments it might write star
tree memory because it was toast you
could just write to the arbitrary memory
yourself
but those interfaces still exist on
currently shipping systems there if you
boot a new UEFI system with the
compatibility services module so it
looks like it's still running BIOS you
still have a whole number of BIOS
interrupts available to you that can
still be calls from the operating
systems that still then jump into the
firmware is execute code none of this
has gone away so this is not some new
issue UEFI is not the big concern here
the problem is that firmware has always
been this bad it just messes more now
where is your firmware your firmware is
all over the place
there's firmware in your motherboard
chipset there's firmware on the embedded
controller theum the thing that makes
your fans work and makes the power
button work
there's firmware in your network
hardware there's firmware in your SSD
there's firmware everywhere it is
everywhere the firmware is definitely
inside the house it's also outside the
house it's above us it's below stairs
firmware everywhere and yeah there's a
lot of firmware the firmware I'm going
to be concentrating on is stuff that is
running on the host CPU but firmware
exists in other places and it is in fact
to mantra bleed the case that firmware
in other places also has security issues
there was a recent paper published that
looked at the security of self
encrypting SSDs and it's cool several of
them had magic calls you can make to the
firmware that allows you to overwrite
bits of the firmware in RAM which in
cases where they were doing decryption
by you giving us a password it checking
that the password was the expected
passwords and then it's unlocking the
disk as opposed to it generating a key
based on the passwords you could just
disable that check give us any passwords
and then happen
unlock so firmware in a lot of these
places is security relevant even if it
doesn't immediately look like it would
be that dangerous system management
modes which I lose it to earlier is a
magical feature of x86 so system
management mode was introduced in the
386 SLC which was Intel's first attempt
at a laptop specific CPU the reason it
has system management mode was so that
you could have a timer that would
repeatedly trap into system management
mode so that it could then turn fans on
and off so even back in history laptops
were trouble but one system management
modes have been used for this purpose
people started realizing well ok
I don't trust operating system authors
to get things right I'm gos Poquoson
system management mode and then my code
will run regardless of what the
operating system does and I can make
sure everything is fine this has worked
out exactly as well as you'd expect it
to the great thing about system
management mode among the great things
about system management mode so you
can't cede the code system management
mode when you trap into it execute code
from an area of RAM that is hidden from
the operating system you can't touch it
which is in a sense good because system
manager mode is also then in a position
to scribble over the entirety of address
space so it's kind of bad if you were
able to just multiply that codes and
then trapped in system management those
you could do what if you wanted so
obviously it's great that that is
literally impossible it's not literally
impossible system magic mode is also
privileged as I mentioned earlier once
you write protect flash on Intel
platforms if you attempt to switch the
write protect bits back off that
generates a system management interrupt
the system stops running the SMM code
pops up decides you probably didn't want
to do that and
protects the flash again so that
prevents you from at the operating
system level rewriting your Flash so
this is helpful from a security
perspective good work system management
knows unfortunately there's also a lot
of other entry points to system
management mode and those can include
things like well you know backlight
control on various systems is under
system measure modes there's all sorts
of weird cases where you pass some
arguments and then the world stops some
magic happens in the world starts again
sometimes what happens when the world
stops is the pointer to some RAM that
you pass the system management mode that
the system management mode code assumed
would always be a specific area of
memory that was allocated as playas only
instead points at say your kernel at
which point you trapped in the system
management mode and your kernel gets
overwritten and its behavior probably
changes as a result so the consequences
are hilarious unless it's a system
physical system that belongs to you in
which case it's less hilarious so I
don't want non ac6 platforms to feel
left out arm looked at x86 and they
looked at system management mode and
apparently they thought gosh we can do
better than this
we can put an entire operating system in
system management mode so trust zone is
a CPU feature on arm it divides the
world into normal world which is what we
call a computer and secure mode which is
what we call not secure in the normal
world you have your operating system you
have your applications and you have a
driver this allows you to talk to trust
zone in trust zone you have a kernel
that is running and environments that
execute the t'ee or a trusted execution
environment stuff in trust zone is not
supposed to be accessible from user
lands so if you say it wants to
implement DRM you can do that
by putting your DRM stack in trust zone
and then the keys are in an area where
the normal world can't get them because
the secure Wells is secure it says so
turns out secure world's not
particularly secure because trust zone
is made of code and bugs so people have
found multiple mechanisms for getting
our tree codes execution with interest
so yeah unsurprisingly different vendors
have their own kernels for running
interest so and so sometimes some of the
things people use trusted for a kind of
interesting Samsung had an extension of
their Knox architecture which meant that
the kernel could only allocate executive
all pages in kernel space by calling out
to trust zone and asking trust owner to
do it so the idea there being that trust
zone could verify that this request was
coming from a past the kernel that
should be attempting to allocate execs
full pages and otherwise it was probably
malware and shut it down
obviously inevitably this turns out to
be bug ins exploitable but firmware on
your phone yeah it's as bad as firmware
anywhere else's not all run time
firmware is system management mode you
also have a bunch of a CPI codes a CPI
is actually not too big a concern as
long as you're not allowing our tree
people to inject arbitrary a CPI tables
there's a kernel feature this allows the
injection of new a CPI codes at runtime
if you allow that then someone can just
inject a piece of a CPI codes that
overwrites your kernel again or specific
bits of your kernel you can bring here
sellar that way there's a bunch of yeah
don't do that
you look like you efi runtime services
you've got stuff like the ability to set
variables which is how you tell you efi
where your bootloader is and there are
various other bits and pieces as well
that's more concerning because that is
running in a more dangerous context it's
not constrained in the way that a CPI is
you if i runtime code can basically do
whatever it was
manfist engine so this one is Intel's
fault we in fel decided that having one
x86 core per x86 system wasn't
sufficient and recent Intel chipsets
have another x86 core running the
management engine which is actually what
comes up before the CPU starts running
the management engine gets its own
firmware execute that verifies
potentially the rest of your firmware
brings the CPU up and then the CPU
starts excusing the rest of the firmware
these days the management engine runs
MINIX which is an operating system which
is made of code people have determined
that it is possible to so management
engine verifies its firmware but the
firmware contains a file system it's
possible to tamper with that file system
in ways that it won't detect until later
in the boot process and someone found a
way to modify that in such way they
could get arbitrary code execution on
the management engine which is great
someone's running me I know probably not
a Bitcoin miner on your management
engine because it would really not be
very fast but definitely conceivable so
if you're in a situation where an
attacker is able to trigger artery code
execution in your firmware and spoiler
you probably are in one of those
situations they're able to tamper with
the entire chain of trust that your
system has they're able to break any of
your other validation steps so the only
security is a big deal we really need to
care about it
so thankfully over the past few years
while we are still writing bugs we are
also writing code that helps bugs be
less dangerous we have got to the point
where we've basically accepted that it's
impossible to avoid writing bugs but we
can write compilers that are better at
preventing bugs from being exploitable
how much of this is actually happening
in our firmware so first thing we can do
in order to reduce the probability that
bugs will be exploitable is just to
reduce the attack surface if the
firmware never touches untrusted data
then it's much more difficult to exploit
security vulnerabilities in the firmware
like what well it's partly by definition
all right so trusted code is never going
to do something malicious right never so
the problem is that we do at some point
have to execute some code because
otherwise you have a computer that boots
firmware and then does nothing else
which in some ways is the Platonic ideal
of a computer but in other ways is not
actually what you purchase the computer
for so the more functionality we can
remove from firmware arguably the better
our firmware security is so that's good
second approach is that we can perform
the same source of mitigation strategies
that we do in the operating system we
can put stack Canaries there so that if
something overflows the stack we can
detect that and end execution we can use
SLR to put the firmware at random
locations in memory when it's executing
so that it's more difficult for an
attacker to overwrite specific bits of
firmware or get arbitrary code execution
we can make the stack
on executive also that if someone does
manage to inject codes onto the stack
they're not able to jump into it these
are things that we've been doing on the
actual OS level for some time now
firmware is also beginning to do this
UEFI there are definitely UEFI
implementations that have all of this
functionality which means it is more
difficult to then take advantage of any
bugs that exist of course we could just
not right bugs so generally speaking
whenever a piece of software has a
security vulnerability that's basically
caused because C is security
vulnerabilities as a language someone
will pop up and say oh no the problem
isn't see the problem is that your
programmers are not sufficiently
competent and a fun thing to do is to
then find any projects that that person
works on and look for CVS because
generally speaking they're saying this
despite having a bunch of high-priority
security issues with their code we are
not able to avoid writing bugs so the
best we can really do is reduce the
amount of code to the extent that the
number of bugs is manageable build the
software in such a way that the bugs
that do exist are less likely to be
security vulnerabilities and then also
ensure that when we do find bugs we're
able to fix them and provide updates to
people so that they can patch the bugs
it's not just about code quality those
security issues that are triggered by
firmware are not necessarily a result of
the firmware having the sorts of thing
that we think of as a security
vulnerability there's a lot of hardware
that needs to be configured correctly in
order to ensure that the system is
running in a trustworthy state and not
all firmware does all of this there's a
piece of software called chip SEC you
can grab that and run it and it will
tell you whether your firmware has
configured
system correctly in order to avoid
security issues so chipset school
wholeheartedly recommend running that
just to see how bad things are it does
involve building a kernel module so if
you have a secure boot turned on your
knees figure that's out so we can reduce
the tank surface in various ways Linux
boot is a payload for existing UEFI PE I
list so the pei is the pre efi
initialization step of the UEFI system
it's the code that brings your hardware
up and gets you to a state where you can
then run UEFI proper linux pose is a
project that basically takes the
existing pei code and then shims a new
layer on top of that instead of the
existing dixie code and you basically
just have your firmware jump straight
into a kernel and then from that
perspective that's how things is quite
like the pettit boots that stewart was
talking about earlier you're then able
to use Linux and as we know Linux
doesn't contain any security
vulnerabilities but yeah yeah bits is a
pretty much from scratch implementation
of the UEFI spec that is a viable
payload for core boot so it's a much
smaller UEFI implementation and less
code should mean fewer bugs an
interesting thing that shows up recently
is called project mu and this is
actually a Microsoft initiative they are
attempting to basically take the Tiano
reference UEFI code but make it more
maintainable and make it more agile
they're attempting to do more aggressive
security work there with the goal of
pushing it back into Tiano but it's kind
of weird when Microsoft released the
source code for a whole bunch of the
firmware that runs on their surface
devices and post on github
2019 is strange
so right now mu is not something you can
build as a payload for coreboot but it's
so you can't easily take mu right now
and build it and run it on any other
systems but it is a interesting Avenue
of potentially making things better
many people say just use core boosts and
promise coreboot doesn't inherently save
us coreboot is if you can build a core
boot image for your system and flash it
then great you have the ability to
update firmware you can patch bugs and
fix vulnerabilities and reflash it and
that's great but Corbitt itself is not
the problem here
coreboot mostly doesn't expose any
runtime services Coburg mostly doesn't
handle untrusted input
Courbet itself we could write giant bugs
into coreboot and from a security
perspective it wouldn't matter because
there's no way for an attacker to get at
that code because coreboot isn't there
at the point where an attacker is able
to do something instead it's the
payloads that call boot launches that
provides most of the runtime attack
service this isn't strictly true there's
some system management mode code does
come from Cole boots itself rather than
the payloads but overall Cobras itself
we don't need to worry about from the
security perspective it's very difficult
to write a meaningful x86 firmware that
doesn't use system management those at
some point like I mentioned if you want
to protect your flash you have to use
system management mode unfortunately
right now Cori payloads mostly don't
implement flash protection which is it's
something you can turn on but then if
you ever want to update your firmware
you have to attach a flash programmer to
your system and reflash it by hand you
can't then easily do updates at runtime
so yeah there's trade-offs here
so I'm going to talk about some of the
oh sorry management engine yeah if you
have a man contention before version 12
there's no rollback protection someone
with physical access can flash older
management engine firmware onto it and
it will execute that which means even if
you've patched your system so that it
doesn't have any known management engine
vulnerabilities someone with physical
access can forcibly downgrade the
firmware to a version that does still
have vulnerabilities so unfortunate one
option is to buy a new computer that has
version 12 management engine the
alternative is you know if someone
doesn't have physical access it's
probably not too bad so just don't give
your laptops to untrustworthy people
like me so I wouldn't lose too much
sleep about the management engine is
definitely a security concern for
certain types of user but practically
speaking no one is likely to take
advantage of these vulnerabilities the
best thing that someone can do in
general is just make sure that your
system is running the latest version of
the firmware and the loan spends a
firmware service or l VPS is a service
that provides industry standard UEFI
capsule update files and several vendors
now contribute to this so your firmware
updates now come through can be applied
with a similar experience to any other
software update and vendors are also now
supplying on non-load systems vendors
are now also supplying their firmware
via Windows updates so we're actually
seeing that side of things get a lot
better it used to be a colossal pain to
do firmware updates now it's just
something that happens magically behind
your back not at all concerning so as
long as your system vendor actually
patches security relevant issue
applying foamer updates is probably good
enough that is something of a
presumption to make but you know some of
them are not too bad at this if you want
to run your own firmware on a system
then what are your options in terms of
trade-offs between your functionality
and security you can build TR know the
reference UEFI implementation as a
payload for core boosts and then you can
flash that into your firmware and in
fact it's what I'm running on this
laptop so this is an apparently
hopefully normal ufi UEFI base laptop
except it's running a firmware image
that I built which so to clarify I
didn't write it I just built it
unfortunately the Tiamo payloads doesn't
have support for secure boot and it
doesn't really do firmware flash
protections so you can choose between
either your system is secure against
attacks attackers just reflashing
getting roots and then rewriting your
firmware or you can choose a system
where you can actually do firmware
updates without needing to take your
machine apart first it's definitely a
trade off so that will get better before
too long if you are willing to not tie
yourself directly to x86 then you have
other options so as Stuart was talking
about earlier the open power platform
has basically open firmware all the way
up that does have these security
characteristics you would probably like
it to have and you can rebuild that
yourself and refresh your system there
are various arm platforms that are well
a lot of the new interesting arm devices
coming out are running proprietary
vendor UEFI stacks and so have it's not
straightforward to replace the firmware
on them but there are various other arms
vices where you can basically replace
the firmware yourself some of these
pretty much just run you boot as their
firmware it's just a jump into here
start executing code and that
happens to be something that can
initialize the hardware but is also a
bootloader you boots not a magic make on
my security concerns go away solution
though unfortunately I played a little
with taking the u-boot filesystem codes
putting that into a small user and test
harness and then building it with AFL or
American fuzzy lob which is a fuzzer
that's instruments decode and tries to
figure out how to change the input in
such a way that it runs different code
paths turns out that if you feed the you
big file system codes malformed file
systems you get some interesting bugs
and thankfully file systems are not
something that yeah obviously file
systems are something that can be under
control of an attacker if for instance
you support booting off USB attack it
walks up plugs in the USB stick if the
file system can be malformed in a way
that gives you archery codes execution
any of your other security guarantees
have gone again so I it's not ideal but
it is of course open source and you are
able to fix these bugs and update your
system or wait for someone else to fix
the bugs and they're not to your system
so in some ways better than elsewhere if
you have a Chromebook and want complete
control of your firmware then you're in
luck you can rebuild the firmware from
scratch entirely if you want to actually
flash the entire firmware then
unfortunately you do need to disassemble
well on the older Chromebooks you need
to disassemble the machine in order to
remove a screw that allows you to
actually write to the initial bit of
flash that contains the initial
verification keys for the rest of the
firmware because with luck you don't
have access to Google's firmware signing
keys just if any of you do please let me
know but it's it's not super
straightforward to redo everything so
you replace the keys with your own keys
but you can do it you can rebuild your
firmware sign it with your own keys
instead and then alright you have a
complete firmware implement
more recent robots you don't have to
disassemble them there's a physical
presence test based on a hotkey this
allows you to disable the right
protection that way if you are super
advanced then you have the opportunity
to try to run V boos which is the core
Chromebook verified boot infrastructure
as a cold boot target on a non
Chromebook platform it's not
fundamentally ties to Chromebooks in any
ways so I'd be really interested if
anybody has actually attempted to do
this I wasn't able to find any
documented cases of people doing so
which doesn't mean it hasn't happened
only problem there is that if you are
concerned about physical present attack
because sorry attacks based on someone
having physical presence then most
machines don't have the same setup where
you can easily modify the state of the
wreck rotate spin on the flash so you
don't have a way of ultimately
protecting the initial set of
verification keys at the beginning of
the flash so it's not necessarily going
to be quite as good as it would be if
you were doing this on Chromebook cars
were but otherwise I don't see any
reason why you would be unable to build
basically the chromos security model on
a general-purpose x86 laptop as long as
you're able to reflash it with Corbett
in the first place so documentation for
V lose is there so I sort of led you
here with the promise that I'd be able
to tell you how to make your machines
good and secure and unfortunately that
was a lie in most cases I don't actually
have a good answer for you most of the
options that involve you running open
code also involve you making some sorts
of trade-offs around security so depends
on what your threat model is the best
approach differs if you ultimately want
freedom then right now that probably
does involve making some compromises on
the security front upside is you are
able to do this in the way that well you
can fix all the other security
vulnerabilities and fix your system
yeah the world is sadly not perfect so
that is everything I am going to present
we have five minutes or so for questions
[Applause]
thank you for an excellent presentation
what are your thoughts on disabling
management engine kind of work that
companies like purism and others are
doing thank you
the management engine is in general
running all time and you can't disable
it entirely because otherwise your CPU
never boots which again kind of defeats
the purpose of having a computer so the
approach that has been taken is that
there's a bit you can set that does
basically cause the management engine to
stop executing most codes after its
subsystem bring up there's an app called
any cleaner which you can also use to
remove most of the codes that runs on
the management engine which reduces the
attack surface significantly so yeah
that's something you can definitely do
and you probably do get some security
benefit from doing so
do you have any opinion on the viability
of the super micro BMC hack that was
been the patent news life not whether it
actually happened but whether it was
actually plausible okay so backgrounds
here Bloomberg
produced a story towards the end of last
year where they asserted that super
micro motherboards shipped to various
vendors various customers had been
modified with the introduction of a
small implant that compromised the BMC
and then back to all the rest the system
as a result there has been very very
strong denials that this actually
happens for a bunch of affected people I
am not in any position to say with
certainty that it didn't happen thought
it is happen in terms of the
plausibility though so Trammell Hudson
gave a presentation at CCC the very end
of last year where he demonstrated a
proof-of-concept implementation of this
he built a implants that is with a one
wire connection capable of modifying the
SPI data coming off flash in such a way
that the BMC ends up running modified
code so it is technically possible
whether it happens no clue the Intel
management engine you mentioned it runs
MINIX
why do you reckon that's the case and
why not something like free artists or
whatever else why is the management
engine running MINIX and so from some
perspectives when you're implementing
something one of the things you have to
care about is how easy is it going to be
to continue finding people to maintain
this codebase in the long run or to add
functionality to it one of the reasons
that the x86 industry went with UEFI
rather than just going with open
firmware was that it's not easy finding
fourth programmers
and it's also difficult finding people
who are enthusiastic about learning
fourth so in that case you if I was a
way of getting C developers into
firmware development so it would not
surprise me if the choice of MINIX was
largely around just we know we have
people who know how to target POSIX like
operating systems and so MINIX is a
small implementation of a positive like
operating system and presumably the
licensing terms were also appealing
hi thank you very much for the talk
quick question how well would a
hypervisor isolate say untrusted code
from your firmware depends on the
implementation of the hypervisor so for
instance key VM something running as a k
vm guest has basically zero access to
the system firmware so running all
untrusted code in a hypervisor like that
is yeah isolating it great you've made
the world a better place for yourself
there something like but it depends on
the design for hypervisor for instance
dom0
in an environment is technically running
under a hypervisor but also has direct
access to most hardware resources and in
that case the hypervisor won't do
anything to save you you could certainly
mask off accesses to sensitive resources
and basically prevent the code running
and on 0 from being able to touch
anything that's released to the firmware
you do then end up with a system that
you probably can't use but you could do
it
I Matthew um are you aware of any
vendors that do a particularly good job
of firmware or are they all terrible uh
so I can't really give any strong
feedback on that I know that if you look
at lvl VPS you can lvf s sorry you can
look at which vendors are uploading as a
reasonably high cadence you can look at
how far back their supporting devices so
that might give you a metric that you
could use to come some sources decision
there
we've got a small token of appreciation
here thank you very much for an amazing
talk thank you
[Applause]